sur europe bonjour et bienvenue dans
zone europe / sensation une émission
enregistrée au parlement européen de
strasbourg est réalisée en association
avec tv 78 voici le sommaire de ce
nouveau numéro
dans un instant l'euro député
françois-xavier bellamy sera mon invité
l'occasion d'évoquer le bras de fer
entre l'union européenne et la
biélorussie et les tensions entre l'ue
et la turquie
les pères fondateurs de l'europe nous
parlerons de robert schuman un français
né au luxembourg avec la nationalité
allemande
je voyageais dans l'assiette nous vous
ferons découvrir un plat typiquement
suédois le pain de viande les
expressions populaires avoir autre chose
à faire les français disent avoir
d'autres chats à fouetter les anglais
disent avoir d'autres poissons à frire
que dit-on ailleurs c'est ce que nous
verrons à la fin de cette émission
mais avant que fait l'europe dans notre
région un exemple plus saône robe
l'europe dans ma région
aujourd'hui je reçois amandine burgaud
chargée de relations presse au collectif
pour un service civique européen bonjour
bonjour alors on va parler ensemble du
service civique européen vous êtes
bénévole au sein du collectif quel est
votre parcours et qu'est ce qui vous a
donné envie de rejoindre cette aventure
alors moi j'ai fait des études en
rapport avec les langues qui sont peu à
peu orienté vers tout ce qui était
europe et citoyenneté européenne
donc qui concerne la mobilité des jeunes
principalement puisque c'est comme ça
qu'on devient citoyen européen en
voyageant pour la plupart des jeunes du
coup un jour par hasard je tombe sur une
annonce qui faisait que le collectif
recruter des bénévoles
donc je me suis dit bon ben pourquoi pas
tenter l'aventuré puis du coup
maintenant ça fait quand même quelques
mois que je suis arrivé à l'équipe
grandit d'une petit à petit on est
maintenant à peu près 180 bénévoles un
peu partout en europe puisque tout le
monde n'est pas en france ou même ne
serait-ce qu'à paris et du coup
maintenant s'agrandit on essaye de
toucher un maximum de jeunes pour
pouvoir faire grandir la peinture est
alors quelles sont les différences entre
un service civique européen et un
service civique traditionnelle alors le
service civil traditionnels les jeunes
font des missions d'intérêt général en
france pour le service civique européen
on leur propose de lui faire six mois en
france dans la démission de leur choix
et six mois après encore européen de
solidarité donc dans un pays où le pays
européens de leur choix sur la mission
qui les qui leur plaît et qui peut
prétendre pardon un cee est ce qu'il ya
des conditions spécifiques pour
rejoindre un service civique européen
alors les seules conditions ces deux
d'entrer dans les catégories d'âge donc
entre 18 et 25 ans 30 ans pour les
jeunes en situation de handicap
mais après non il n'y a pas de de faut
être jeune et s'intéresser finalement à
l'europe à la mobilité européenne
je pense que tous les jeunes ne
s'intéressent pas forcément la mobilité
européenne laisser l'opportunité offerte
en fait de s'engager dans un dans des
missions d'intérêt général qui leur
plaisent et qui peuvent leur apporter
ensuite des compétences pour trouver un
emploi plus tard ou ne serait-ce que
leur voix comme chaque semaine nous vous
faisons découvrir celles et ceux qui ont
participé à la construction européenne
aujourd'hui robert schuman un français
né au luxembourg avec la nationalité
allemande il est aussi à l'origine de la
fête de l'europe le 9 mai son parcours
avec europe direct et la maison de
l'europe sous une robe sûr sensation
robert schuman est un européen avant
l'heure né en 1886 à clausen au
luxembourg d'un père français et d'une
mère luxembourgeoise il devient allemand
lorsque la région a été annexée par
l'allemagne
ils étudient dans différentes
universités en france et en allemagne et
en 1912 il s'installe comme avocat à
metz il est dispensé du service
militaire pour raisons médicales et
suite à la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale il redevient français en 1919
après la première guerre mondiale il
s'engage en politique tant à l'échelon
local que national en s'engageant dans
conseil municipal à metz et en tant que
député d'alsace moselle au sein de
l'assemblée nationale et un de ses très
grands un de ses grands chantiers va
être de permettre la réintégration de
l'alsace moselle au sein de la
république française tout en leur tout
en permettant à cette région de pouvoir
conserver quelques particularités
locales comme le concordat où le droit
local
en 1940 il est nommé sous secrétaire
d'état pour les réfugiés et participent
au vote des pleins pouvoirs pour pétain
il est arrêté par la gestapo envoyé en
prison puis assigné à résidence
surveillée il finit par s'échapper et
rejoindre la france libre
il finit par s'enfuir après avoir
échappé de peu à une déportation et
finit par s'installer en zone libre
il vivra en clandestinité pendant tout
le reste de la seconde guerre mondiale
sa tête était sa tête ayant été mise à
prix et refusera de rejoindre le
gouvernement livre le gouvernement libre
à londres
préférant plutôt organiser les réseaux
de la résistance sur place après la
guerre ils se consacrent de nouveau à la
politique
en entrant au service de la quatrième
république en devenant ministre donc il
a occupé successivement les postes de
ministre des finances puis premier
ministre en 1947 ministre des affaires
étrangères de 1948 à 1952 ministre de la
justice de 1955 et 1956
il joue enfin un rôle déterminant dans
la négociation des différents traités
européens ainsi que l'adhésion de la
france vous conseille de l'union
européenne et au plan marshall et aussi
à l'otan le 9 mai 1950 il prononce à la
surprise générale sa fameuse déclaration
schuman déclaration schuman qui propose
justement la mise en commun des
productions de charbon et d'acier entre
la france et l'allemagne
il propose donc les productions de
charbon et d'acier soit placée sous le
contrôle d'une autorité supranationale
grâce à cette coopération économique il
était convaincu que la guerre
deviendrait non seulement impossible
impensable mais matériellement
impossible cette déclaration du 9 mai
1950 et l'acte fondateur de ce qui
deviendra plus tard la ceca communauté
européenne du charbon et de l'acier qui
saura l'ancêtre de la cee communauté
économique européenne qui deviendra
l'union européenne tels que telle que
nous la connaissons actuellement il
devient en 1958 le premier président de
l'assemblée parlementaire européenne
en 1960 il quitte ses fonctions et se
retire dans sa demeure à scy-chazelles
où il y eut il y passera ces dernières
années notamment à rédiger son unique
livre qui s'appelle pour l'europe et qui
est qui et son testament politique pour
l'union européenne il décédera en 1963
suite à son départ de son poste de
président l'assemblée parlementaire
européenne lui accordera le titre de
père de l'europe afin de le remercier de
l'ensemble de son oeuvre pour la
construction européenne et le quartier
des institutions européennes à bruxelles
porte dorée nabeul porte dorénavant son
nom sonne europe
l'invité politique
je reçois aujourd'hui françois xavier
bellamy vous êtes eurodéputés membres du
groupe du parti populaire européen
bonjour bonjour alors dans l'actualité
le bras de fer entre l'union européenne
et la biélorussie la biélorussie est
accusé d'avoir détourné un avion de
ryanair pour arrêter un dissident alors
en réaction l'union européenne a
interdit son espace aérien aux
compagnies biélorusse et différentes
sanctions économiques ont également été
adoptées contre le régime est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est suffisant comme
réaction
c'était nécessaire en tous les cas parce
que ce que nous avons vécu c'est un acte
de piraterie aérienne commis par un état
qui a détourné un avion avec tous les
risques que cela implique pour tous les
passagers pour arrêter un opposant
politique qui était protégé en europe
avec le statut de réfugié et il ya
quelque chose qui est évidemment appelé
dans un acte aussi grave une réaction
forte de l'union européenne d'abord
parce que nous devons absolument
garantir la sécurité aérienne et c'est
la raison pour laquelle il était
nécessaire d'interdire l'espace aérien
biélorusse tant que tant que nous savons
l'état biélorusse capable de tels
agissements et puis je crois qu'il ya
aussi une question qui est plus
fondamental encore qui est celle de la
place que nous accordons à la liberté
dans les pays européens en europe
quelqu'un qui est protégé doit pouvoir
être respecté dans sa liberté de parole
et si nous n'y prenons pas garde nos
pays vont devenir le terrain de jeu de
puissance étrangère qui viendront
réprimer leurs opposants jusque chez
nous puisque dans nos villes c'est le
cas de romane protasiewicz et nous
devons exiger sa libération absolument
justement comment est-ce qu'on peut
l'exigé par quels moyens il ya des
moyens de pression supplémentaire qu'on
peut appliquer mais justement ce levier
économique que vous évoquez me paraît
clé la biélorussie aujourd'hui c'est un
pays qui ne peut pas faire sans l'accès
au marché européen nous devons
absolument
aller aussi loin qu'il le faudra pour
garantir que robin de potasser ville
soit soit libéré mais je pense à
d'autres situations
c'est l'occasion pour moi de dire un mot
de la situation de mamad mir ali qui est
un opposant au président d'azerbaïdjan
le monde en parlera tout alief
aujourd'hui il est menacé et sa vie a
été directement mis en danger en france
donc l'europe doit nos pays européens se
doivent de protéger la liberté qu'il
qu'il qu'ils accueillent et à laquelle
il donne l'asile sinon encore une fois
nous ne nous feront pas respectés alors
on parlait de biélorussie le président
biélorusse alexandre loukachenko est au
pouvoir depuis 1994 c'est très
particulier il a été réélu cinq fois et
il fait c'est un fait assez rare pour le
souligner l'unanimité contre lui parmi
les 27 pays membres de l'union
européenne
est ce que vous pensez justement que le
président biélorusse représente à lui
même une menace pour l'union européenne
je suis pas sûr qu'il suffise à
constituer une menace pour l'union
européenne ce qui est absolument
incontestable en revanche c'est que
l'union européenne ne peut pas sauf à se
mettre elle même en danger accepter des
comportements comme celui ci pour le
respect par la russie c'est important le
fait qu'il soit soutenu par la russie
explique qu'il soit au pouvoir ce que la
vérité c'est que effectivement alexandre
loukachenko ne ne représente pas
réellement son peuple mais ça d'une
certaine manière si vous voulez c'est
tout le problème des limites de notre
capacité d'action nous pouvons nous en
ligne et nous pouvons dénoncer
nous ne pourrons pas faire en sorte à
nous tout seul que le le le régime
d'alexandre loukachenko tombe ce que ce
que nous avons le devoir de faire en
revanche c'est 2 2
de protéger d'une manière efficace ce
qui sont accueillis dans nos pays sous
le régime de l'asile politique et cela
c'est non négociable
alors un autre pays avec lequel il ya
quelques tensions avec l'union
européenne c'est la turquie vous dites
je vous cite surpris de voir comment
l'europe se laisse intimider par la
turquie la turquie qui souvent choisis
la façon dont se passent les relations
avec l'union européenne faisant valoir
le fait qu'elle accueille la plus
importante population de réfugiés au
monde près de 4 millions dont une
majorité de syriens la turquie menace
régulièrement d'ailleurs l'union de
laisser passer des millions de réfugiés
vers l'europe
comment est ce que on peut envoyer un
message fort à la turquie pour répondre
à ces menaces
dans le cas de la turquie l'union
européenne est dans une situation de
silence qui est non seulement désastreux
mais qui est coupable coupable parce que
on a vu la turquie au cours des derniers
mois multiplié les violations du droit
international et les atteintes à
l'intégrité des ses voisins et en
particulier d'états membres de l'union
européenne
c'est le cas de la grèce de chypre qui
ont vu leur territoire et leur espace
souverain souverain attaqué de manière
régulière par par les forces militaires
turcs dont il ya là une stratégie de
déstabilisation qui est parfaitement
concertée par ailleurs la turquie a
soutenu ou organiser des crimes de
guerre extrêmement grave
je pensais ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
encore en libye avec le viol constant de
l'embargo sur les armes
je pense aux dizaines de milliers de
personnes forcées d'être déplacé en
syrie avec l'invasion de du nord de la
syrie par la turquie et puis bien sûr à
la situation en arménie où la turquie a
directement soutenu l'azerbaïdjan qui a
agressé de manière unilatérale
l'arménie et qui retient encore de
manière illégale des prisonniers gare
arménien après tout cela
la seule chose que nous trouvons à faire
c'est d'augmenter les fonds de
préadhésion d'estimer à la turquie c'est
un complément si cette adhésion
cette adhésion je vous aussi de vous dit
que c'est une fiction absurde viendra
jeu on peut expliquer que la turquie est
candidate elle même depuis 87
l'âpre le processus est entré en vigueur
en 2005 si je me trompe pas comment
est-ce qu'on peut expliquer que en 2021
dans soit encore dans un processus
d'adhésion et qu'une décision claire n'a
pas été n'était prise la vérité c'est
que personne n'imagine une seule seconde
que la turquie sera un jour un pays de
l'union européenne ça ça n'a jamais été
possible ça n'a jamais été plausible et
maintenant ça devient absurde de
continuer d'entretenir ce processus
dérisoire et encore une fois scandaleux
parce que les pays du monde entier nous
regarde et que nous passons notre temps
à parler d'état de droit de valeur quoi
ça sert alors ça le respect de l'égalité
homme-femme et qu'à la fin nous
finançons la turquie donc évidemment
tout le monde ne peut que voir que
l'europe est complètement incohérent la
vérité c'est que il ya plusieurs raisons
qui expliquent qu'ils expliquent cette
passivité dramatique
la première raison c'est qu'il ya des
intérêts économiques très fort entre la
turquie et l'europe notamment des hommes
des intérêts industriels
la deuxième raison c'est que beaucoup de
pays européens je pense à l'allemagne en
particulier la france est aussi
concernée ont des communautés turques
importantes sur leur sol qui vote
régulièrement plus favorablement encore
à erdogan que ne le font les turcs qui
habite en turquie donc erdogan fait de
la politique dans nos pays d'une
certaine manière
grâce à cette immigration illégale et
cette immigration illégale ils sont
faits le leu leu leu leu leu remparts
mais la vérité c'est que erdogan est
devenu le spécialiste pour se décrire
comme le prestataire des problèmes qu'il
crée lui-même parce que c'est cette
déstabilisation constante de la région
autour de lui qui produit ces flux
migratoires
la vérité c'est car dogan a intérêt à ce
que des millions de personnes vivent sur
son sol que des millions de personnes
soit dans cette situation de 2,2
d'errance et que d'une certaine manière
il constitue le levier par lequel il
fait pression sur l'europe il faut
dénoncer cette situation il faut mettre
fin au processus d'adhésion
il faut supprimer tous les financements
destinés à la turquie c'est ce que nous
réclamons depuis longtemps avec notre
délégation au parlement européen
et j'espère que nous y parviendrons mais
en attendant en attendant l'europe
encore une fois s'inflige un discrédit
qui ne peut que nous rendre plus
vulnérables encore alors vous le disiez
à la turquie en septembre 2020 à appuyer
l'azerbaïdjan quand elle a attaqué le
haut karabakh une région peuplée
majoritairement d'arméniens
l'arménie justement vous vous y êtes
rendu en avril dernier alors qu'elle
était l'objet de ce déplacement
l'objet de ce déplacement c'est de dire
le soutien que nous
on peuple arménien le soutien que
malheureusement nous n'avons pas su lui
apporter pendant la guerre dont il a été
victime puisque l'arménie a été attaqué
par l'azerbaïdjan soutenu donc pas par
la turquie par des mercenaires
djihadistes qui ont été mobilisés depuis
la syrie pour venir combattre contre
l'arménie
aujourd'hui nous avons encore beaucoup à
faire pour soutenir les arméniens dans
l'épreuve qu'ils traversent
je pense à cette question des
prisonniers de guerre arméniens qui sont
retenus illégalement en azerbaïdjan vous
avez aujourd'hui en arménie dès que nos
auditeurs se rendent compte des dizaines
de familles qui ne savent pas si leur
fils est encore vivant c'est une
situation intenable
l'azerbaïdjan les considèrent comme
terroristes c'est ça l'azerbaïdjan les
retient en disant qu'ils sont non pas
des prisonniers de guerre mais des
terroristes qui ce qui est absurde ccc
contraire aux faits c'est contraire aux
engagements que l'azerbaïdjan a pris à
la fin de la guerre c'est contraire aux
conventions de genève au droit
international bref on est dans une
situation de crimes de guerre et c'est
un recel de crimes de guerre en fait
auquel nous avons à faire et l'europe
doit maintenant se mobiliser
moi je suis très heureux au parlement
européen nous ayons pu voter enfin une
résolution sur ce sujet que j'ai
contribué à porter avec plusieurs
collègues et qui a été voté par plus de
600 parlementaires sur les 688 qui se
sont exprimées cette majorité écrasante
elle dit la réalité de ce problème très
grave auquel nous sommes confrontés et
la nécessité d'agir pour aider l'arménie
dans cette situation terrible
merci beaucoup françois-xavier bellamy
d'avoir été mon invité sur sensations je
rappelle que vous êtes eurodéputés et
membre du groupe du parti populaire
européen
merci à vous une invitation au voyage à
présent un voyage dans l'assiette cette
semaine direction la suède robert jarl
le chef du restaurant lilac rügen à
saint germain en laye dans les yvelines
du dévoile la recette de son pain de
viande
sony europe voyage oui bonjour je suis
chez flaubert je tiens le restaurant tu
lis la créo guen à saint-germain-en-laye
depuis
maintenant 7 ans et
aujourd'hui jeu va vous montrer le pan
devions une flaque c'est stupide sur moi
qui est ma che est plutôt est ce qu'on
m'a dit le plat quotidienne qui moi je à
revisiter à ma façon pourrait être plus
adapté à l'est la restauration dans la
recette on a le viande hachée des
oignons des carottes des pleurotes et et
on utilise aussi une appareil avec du
chapelet des oeufs et du club pour avec
ça on va réaliser une ketchup de
betteraves et framboises et pour ça il
ne faut des oignons doux et le framboise
de betteraves et du tout mais on va
commencer à préparer le base de la
recette qui est le pont de vianne soit
main on à redescendre dans le castro
dans le poêlon naître les unes peu
d'huile pour faire revenir la baule les
sonnions et on m'a laissé on laissait
les sonnions cuisant pour devenir le
petit port
plus vous qui les carottes c'est le plus
bas c'est cela qui est le plus dur en
puissant qu avant et voilà on est les
oignons et après avec ça on plante de
une petite peau du foie blé pois bleu
noir concassées maintenant on va laisser
ça et bien ceci avant de mettre les
pleurotes
les pleurotes finement tâche est comme
ça maintenant les oignons et le les
cadeaux est saisie on a notre viande
hachée dans ce cul de poule on ajoute à
on ajoute le apparaît avec de chapelure
des oeuvres qui est dû qu il m on
ajouterait une petite vaisselle
oui voilà on peut mettre en poney de
même que l'europe
il pleut bien cessé jusqu'à ce qu'ils se
réduit à peu près à la moitié et le les
oignons et les carottes ils sont de plus
que le compte qu'ils sont bienne
nous on vient de vous et que les
pleurotes a pris une toute petit peu de
colonnes et ensuite pour réaliser leurs
tubes et robe framboise comprendre un
peu d'huile de tournesol
on laisse ça chauffe bien
[Musique]
on a essayé c'est du leap le betteraves
les framboises le thomas du balsamique
et moi j'utilise produits suédois c2c le
sucre et de mélasse on pensait de
menaces reçu que 2
deux bêtes à sucre
quand les oignons commence à colorer et
c'est bien concept bien chaud dans la
poêle
on ajouterait le sucre
voir
[Musique]
conde quand le sucre à bien car il me
laissait ont des glaces au vinaigre
balsamique
on ajoute notre framboises les
betteraves les tomates et on laisse à
rêver avec avec un petit peu de poivre
et du sel
et maintenant quand notre dose mélange
du bureau et de leurs oignons de 40 est
prêt à mélenchon ça ensemble avec nous
apparaît à chaque lot clem et des heures
après on ne mélange salamandre
[Musique]
et voilà on à la patte qu'il faut après
contre la pâte
le mélange de lyon mathieu et ça c'est
bien
et c'est pour ça on appelle ça le pain
de viande après contre la pâte
les mélanges de viande hachée et ça
c'est bien
et c'est pour ça on appelle ça le pain
de viande
appelons valeurs entourées avec les
lames chemin
pour mettre un peu d'huile dans une
plaque pour le four
on le mettrait le pain de viande et on
va mettre ça au four à 175 degrés pour
environ 35 40 minutes
non
et comme quand les catcheurs accueilli
jusqu'à ce qu'ils les oignons les
oignons les betteraves et criait nous
viennent bien compris on mettrait sa
dans une mx 1 et mx l'on met dans le
blender et on ajoute les goûts les sel
et le poivre au saut qui ce qui peut
manquer selon de ces logos plus con
c'est bienne réduite
on maîtrise a vendu dans le blender
pour
[Applaudissements]
après qu'on a passé le nôtre ketchup
dans le blender
on a on a vérifié que le goût il ne voit
ici on le mettrait dans une bouteille
pour pouvoir faire des décorations sur
les assiettes aussi simple pour vous d
acheter une bouteille si vous voulez
faire redescendre pour le dressage
on utilise notre bouteille on peut faire
une petite c'était les âges comme ça
[Applaudissements]
on place le par mu en ondes une petite
seconde
et avec ça pour le petit couleurs etc ou
par un petit peu plus festif en mal de
petites salles
quelques petits combats renner et voilà
c'est ça le le podium je lui dois
les expressions populaires avoir
d'autres choses à faire les français
disent avoir d'autres chats à fouetter
les anglais disent avoir d'autres
poissons à frire que dit-on ailleurs
regardez zone europe
expression d'ici et d'ailleurs en italie
on dit avait real très gâté d'appel à
cela signifie avoir d'autres chats
t'appeler les belges disent avoir
d'autres chats à fouetter
au royaume uni on dit ward fichou frei
cela signifie avoir d'autres poissons à
frire zone europe s'est terminée merci
aux équipes techniques du parlement
européen de strasbourg vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en podcast
audio et vidéo sur notre site notre
application radio sensations et aussi
sur tv 78 rendez vous la semaine
prochaine
bonne soirée sonne europe / sensations